surprise surprise yes i worked at google
as a software engineer some of you
guessed it some of you didn't but um to
be honest it was quite easy to figure
out i'm pretty sure my videos have
leaked this a couple of times
also my badge i'm sure i've leaked this
but um
yeah i'm actually not sure how to return
this so google hr if you're watching
this can you send me an email because
i'm not sure how to return this
um and then also this video alright so
we just finished up with lunch and i'm
about to be my friend
oh man i i wish i could work here gosh
it looks so nice there okay
and then this is youtube ads yt ads
which is pretty funny because you know
i'm a youtuber but um specifically i
worked on mid-rows so you know when we
interrupt you and we show an ad
that's me
sorry i know you guys hate it but
creators love it because that's how they
make more money so don't complain
anyways i quit like mid-november so it's
almost been like a month and a half two
months now
i haven't had the chance to tell you
guys because i was busy creating content
[Music]
all right so why did i quit google as a
software engineer well uh my youtube
channel got to a point where there's
actually more opportunity cost to
staying as a software engineer there's a
lot more upside that i can have if i do
youtube full-time so yeah so that's
pretty much why and then also
you know i just really [ __ ] love
making videos and i i want to make sure
that all my time is spent doing that
think about it i'm just like writing
stupid jokes for you guys and that is my
job so that's pretty damn cool
and in the end you know life's short so
you should do what makes you happy
so here's my plan for the future because
of course i always have a plan when i
quit my job anyways to explain i need to
draw a graph actually before i do that
let me tell you who the sponsor of
today's video is because i am now
unemployed it is nordvpn woohoo
you know honestly thank you so much
nordvpn for allowing me to do this
full-time so thank you and let me talk
about it if you want a good vpn that
protects the things you buy the searches
you make and the websites you visit
check out nordvpn not only does it
encrypt your traffic you can use it to
change your location and watch shows
that are only shown in specific country
if you're interested there is a holiday
season deal going on right now where you
can get 73 off the two-year plan plus
one month free
so if you're interested click on the
link below and use my code
so these are the three main pillars of
growth for me and let me tell you how
they relate to each other
so obviously my number one goal is to be
a film director so that's why this is on
top and as you can see i've made some
videos that are pretty traditionally
made so very fancy and like cinematic
like this one
last year we recovered 800 thousand
dollars in the boa robbery
six months ago the four-year-old son of
a world-renowned pianist was found
thanks to us now we're working on our
biggest homicide case yet that's what we
do we don't have the resources nor the
time for these low-level cases
where do you live commander
the goal is to one day make an hbo
series or a netflix series but that's
like light years ahead so i don't want
to get ahead of myself but for me to get
there i have to experiment with high
production videos like that one which
costed me around 60 grand to make which
is totally not worth it but it did allow
me to learn what is required to make
these types of productions so as you can
see the problem is that even if it's my
top priority i can't focus on it 100
just because it's so expensive right and
also i think i'm not at a point where i
can justify these fancy looking films
since my writing is still kind of
garbage so i'm still focusing on writing
which is why i'm making these kind of
videos i'm not sure if you know but the
joma cinematic universe
where every character is kind of
recurring
because i am practicing my writing
and that's why i make these videos for
you guys
am i right
until i'm confident enough to justify
hey let's spend a lot of money on this
short film clearly i need money to fund
my pashon which is why we have here this
is the midi media company that i want to
build which is honestly a more fancy
name to say i just want to have multiple
youtube channels where some of them i'm
not even in it right i want to be able
to scale which is why i expanded to joma
in nyc for lifestyle videos recall by
data eq for data science specific videos
both of these channels are profitable on
their own and i hope to make more
channels where they can benefit from
cross promotion but different enough to
garner a new audience so honestly i kind
of want to run it like a hedge fund
where instead of portfolio managers you
have channel managers and their bonuses
are based off of the performance of the
channel at the end of the year that'll
be pretty cool i think i think that'll
be pretty cool so i want to build a very
very small company almost kind of like a
lifestyle business where everyone gets
paid super handsomely and they get nice
bonuses and everyone's happy and
everyone's super creative so that's the
vision for my mini media company instead
of paying me handsomely i will take all
of the profits
and fund my film directing so that's how
this leads into that and then for the
third pillar it's crypto so
every so often there's a new technology
that might change the way we do things
and i have no idea if crypto is just a
huge bubble or if it's here to stay but
even if there's a ten percent chance
that it stays and it becomes a
technology that changes the way we do
things i have to put my eggs in it so i
got started in crypto i first bought
some eth tried to learn some d5 by using
like uniswap and other lending protocols
only to realize that the gas fees were
so damn high so as a poor man i decided
to find another chain which is how i got
to solana
why don't we all switch to salada i mean
i heard but if i put you on that they
would kind of blow my mind i haven't had
my mind blown in a long time you just
did it solana solana lap i will remember
that i played with staking my solana
using marinade i played with like
lending and borrowing my coins using
soul and earning a nice apy and then i
started learning about like the history
so i really want to make short films
related to crypto because it's such a
fascinating world and the way for me to
do it is to actually immerse myself into
the crypto world so i can understand it
more so that i can properly write
accurate scripts and stories related to
crypto for example michael lewis
he wrote a lot about the financial
industry the 2008 housing crisis that
was made into a movie called the big
short so i want to make the big short
but
in crypto something related to crypto
and one of the examples is the dao the
one that got 60 million stolen out of it
and then which forced the fork of eth
and eth classic
so in some ways i want to put myself in
a perfect position where possibly i can
get funded by these rich crypto people
by making more crypto films to bring
awareness in an accurate light so for
example which is why i bought this so
this is an ape
it says something called an nft you know
steph curry has one jimmy fallon has one
i just got my first nft you did what was
it i threw moonpay
and i bought uh i bought i bought an ape
okay yeah board aids yeah yeah yeah gary
tan has one so a lot of like important
powerful people
have this ape so it was my way to kind
of try to integrate myself into the
community hopefully and then maybe one
day i can get my films funded by one of
them so in conclusion everything i do is
to support me improving in my filmmaking
skills which means writing directing
producing everything
i want to create a video that i could
call my own and that i am actually proud
of
in the end i just want to make the best
videos that i would enjoy watching
i do want to say that i am very
fortunate
to be in this position where i could
learn and focus on my passion while
getting paid
and i can't thank you guys enough for
that
but yeah so that's the plan
and uh
pretty much [ __ ]
oh
and one more thing
[Music]
this is
uh